i love watching that rehearsal you guys
did
with lady gaga and i'll tell you why
because it's mind-blowing to me
that metallica teamed up with lady gaga
at the grammys
and the rehearsal video first of all she
walks in she's not wearing any pants
like i'm looking at james in that video
i'm going he must be saying jesus christ
maybe i should tell her she's not
wearing pants but it's like the
emperor's new clothes
you know what i mean but i go wow look
at these guys they're able to say hey
here's a fellow musician
let's have some fun with her i just
respect her as an artist you know we had
chatted with her before she walked in
and you know she she was there for two
hours before
we even got there working on her moves
and
thinking stuff up she's extremely
creative
and she's a a fearless artist so and
also when you get when you get to know a
few of these people better you you start
understanding obviously more about their
background and lady gaga in particular i
mean she
loves metal has been very vocal about
her love for metal all the time and
would show up at iron maiden shows and
anthrax shows and
she was telling me that you know metal
militia which is this deep cut on our
first album kill em all was her favorite
song
you know back in the day and so
obviously with her that
that whole thing was was very authentic
and true yeah no it really was i mean i
love that rehearsal video it really has
some great energy to it
she's incredible incredible
you